遠い向かせう2飛行士に憧れて本気で打つを目指した咳があったが思いのほかに虫歯が
を過ぎて打つ行くのは来られたことがある
肇社長です皆さん浮月たくないですか郊外は本当に言われて所
何度ですね宇宙飛行士の方から僕があり
メッセージがと書いてあります
たとえで今回実際さんのムービーがあるのでちょっと皆さんでみましょう
もう今本当に証券ですからねいきますよ
はじめしゃちょーこんにちは
jaxa 宇宙飛行士の2尺会です
私は今地上から約400キロメートル上空を飛行している
国際宇宙ステーション iss に滞在中です jaxa が国際宇宙ステーションの
iss の日本実験棟きぼうで行なっている
最先端の宇宙実験をもっとたくさんの人にわかりやすくお伝えするためにはじめ車場の
力を貸してもらえ
ませんか
肇社長のクリエーターとしての手腕を生かして
ぜひ希望の宇宙実験が市場の生活にどう役に立っているのかをわかりやすく楽しく伝え
て頂ければと思います
今回肇社長希望サイエンスさんロック丸プロジェクトのチーフエクスペリメントオフィ
さに任命しますのでぜひ一度
筑波宇宙センターに足を運んで私たちが行っている宇宙実験を実際に見て感じて
ください
きっと面白いと思いますよ
それではよろしくお願いします
なんかすごいなぁ普通彦氏の方から個別にメッセージを頂けるとあんたが幸せ
まあ今大西さんがおっしゃっていた通り撃っちゃうのそのんでなんかやっていること
ですが難しくて分かりづらいことが多い
で僕は前の実際曽根わかってないところがありまして私が今回をに出場し攻守に託され
ていればちょ
曲で私が弱酸筑波宇宙センターまで行って実際に今宇宙でどのような研究とかで実験と
かされているかっていうのをね
まあ僕と一緒に皆さんでこう学べていけたらいいなと思っております宇宙センターに
行くだけでちょっとビビっちゃうんですけど
溶融から私も jaxa の本葛木と木を切ったかバッハ
うちの近いぞと言う
言い方がザクさん筑波宇宙センターで行ってきます
二大弟子サーん
はいというわけでこちらつくばの普通センターが出来ました
ご覧の通りも言えずにはですねロケットの見本が置いてあります
お客さんどうですか
ちょっとメカの憲法を守っている小さいですよねべきはよく見たらん
時間スペースドームでございます
放送伊勢やすいですよこれないと皆さんテレビ見れなかったわけですから
病気かありがとうははしガスト
くれないですよ
ぽっちゃり前でし国際委員ステージの中に希望の日本のズッキーニとかあっ nous
c 2飛行ちゃんはポイズンいい女性になりません
棒2本付
のライトにレクター
登録可能です
よろしくどうぞよろしくお願いしまーすローン
一色ではそれが終わりすごいの足元まだよ
入っちゃっても入りませんで特に
分
アンパンマン社長の宇宙ってどのぐらいの高さから
ガーッと存知ですかもうものすごい高いと思っている症状があるんですけど一般的には
109れる白い
番組 youtube で定義してます
きっと宇宙空間れてしまえば
無重力ん世界がなっています液体フロントプーリーとか
心霊感を生んでいるのか共有地環境で実験することとの目的で作られたのが国際宇宙士
が国際宇宙ステーションを運用しているのは15カ国
入れて貴方の上についているものがセンター試験
全1件ちょっとの環境へも1点がピロいきます
ロボットアームを使って中阿蘇とにいろんな here 国際注射の here
これをどう完成しているか管制室を説明したいと思いますどうぞよろしくお願いします
けど
てみたことなく
んっても今本当においてやろうところ言わせて
実際に登っよってほとんどのことは地上からコマンドでしてるんですよ
水郷の ufoキャッチャーやっ一袋位
変選手はあります結果を出される栖鳳楼継と対面する渡辺さんですよろしくお願います
距離がありますね僕からですね
一般の方でも公開されていないみたいだよな
そう
ここはホント気密です本当のトップシェイクねほんと良いですねこれから
はプリズムです
me
ですね広いですね皆さんここが
2の人は入れないトップスいくえっとクリーンルームでございます
塩蔵高い
クリームは中に入っている
これが高
実物大の基礎はこのぷっぷ
を買った衛星自体はどんなことに使われている
おーまー坊写真を撮ったりとかとか
表面に led とか
遊説を紫外線だという
だかおもしろい
ねん
一つあっねああ
あの
選外プラットフォーこういうて3ってかとっていたですね
何カ所ありとって心を使って実験できないかなって考えたのかなぁ
発表の拡大
ミッションとしてはその嘘とバーに取り付けてただ単に1年
割とメディアに出ているのはは
パン pop っていう
の山城先生ということだっています
いう方がいん
えあろげると思った
ペロペロやれやれやっほ有機物
あったというかないきたいとおもいます
れる中空間から飛んできたのか
言われたのか
いう形がどちらかというと頑張っ
分かってないね
それあろうまず宇宙ステーションへの飛球に近いけどものであり
今調べている一番のポイントは次から
出てみれば
おもしろっ
つまり質問して催すファイ
普通に生命たいわー
すると思います
思います頑張ってある
あまあそうですまたマーメグリア思ってます
ともあれですかもう
ありませんあああああいますパーティーは5 c
方ははいっ
浮かせる浮かせると思って
あこれですかはい舞空術
客さん舞空術使えますか1
6週間やって嬉しかったよ知らせません
を
ウエイター
静電気を使って
何やりたいかというとレーザーが
こいつを許可した
かせながらのは
費用キャラいろんなもん入ってるって
また9なかっ
ていた
やると
罪状やってきたこと
すればいいじゃん
金属ゲームものを溶かすと酸素があると思う
アーサーそれが錆びちゃうんです
この件い
大
メーカー光があっ
ええってことでもじゃあもしございますよね
とてつもない世界だよええ
今度そうするとなんでも飛ばせるんだ
受けば+がいっぱいついてないと力方がない
売ってる魅力はなくん
この系は
口でおります
ああああああ
地球の宇宙センターの食堂ということでやっぱ基本色は宇宙食なんですか
はっはっは
ほんと一般的なあ日本軍にハイカロリー
ザックさんのポップですよザク砂のポーズちょっと
ジャックさの甜茶れてされません
あった
今日は昼食をご用意し
宇宙しょっ系今後な宇宙食ですよね仕掛けてみましょうこれを大日たも食べていると
いうことです
道
いやーついにバリバリ美味しいですよな
ごちそうダメさやめちゃくちゃおいしかったですか疲れ
ぜひ皆さんも2選択した時は食べてみてください
次はあのタンパク質消し調整政権はい
に関する政府なよ
知しらさんからいい
していただきます
のためファー
犬というすごいリボンの中でですねあのー
タンパク質を使った実験をしているんですけれども私たちの体の中でもですね
ヒューマン種類以上のたんぱく質があ
ねそれ働きも違うんですけれども
構造も違うんですよ二十歳です
実はタンパク質写ってる凄く小さいので顕微鏡で拡大してもこの形は見えません
そのため何をするかというと結晶化
この決勝使うことでこのタンパク質の構造というのが詳細に明らかいい
などで具体的に私たちが宇宙で何をしているかと言うとこのタンパク質の結晶を希望の
中で作っ
いうことをしているということです
世の中にある病気に対する薬っていうのは
合う薬はこの淡白すぎ
というようにそれぞれ相手がいて基準と結合することでスリになっています
これに視覚つかないというものを考えるときにやっぱりタンパク質の放送っていう非常
に大事で何もわからないところでやみくもにこれが基部かられが効かだってやっている
よりもこんなこういう形をしているからここに
行為薬をつけて揚げればバッチリはまって
したんじゃないかというのはわかりやすく売っ
以上でどんだけ頑張ってもなかなかもこれ以上は言い決勝になりませんと
そこででバーになるのが宇宙とりわけ
微小重力状態という特殊な環境を提供できる
日本10件との規模
中にすることになる
物質がゆっくりゆっくり動いた方がいい決勝っていうのはあっ
キレイ
っていうのが調べせ
その特徴を活かして宇宙でパチッとした
字幕はっきりはたい写真が撮れるということで今日はですねその結晶化を
実際に
やってもらおうと思います人工血液といってあの輸血の代わりになるものを作る研究を
鉄でさせていく
人工血液のもとになるたんぱく質
こう使って2000系消化していたこれの結晶数
はいじゃあまずガラスキャピラリーをとってください
とりましたとりました妻
じゃあここに刺して
3/4くらい
どうぞを持ってください
そしたら
この刺したがばと反対の上側ですね
上側を
粘土粘土で封をしてください
あーに来ましたそしたらいい
粘土がついていない側に
サシャ現地分はい
def
十分ですよそこでじゃあ俺肇社長あなたは初めての継承かという
我々の仕事は宇宙に単純にたんぱく質を持っていくだけではなくて
このいいケツ症が出る溶液の条件を決定するというのも
仕事です
2つのノードの違いのものがガラス管の中で発生するわけですよ
そうするとその酒豪の良いどこかで条件があったと思うので決勝がおっ
この中でナンパの実験
今こうやっていますそこもまさに一般の方は入れない入れません
キュレット損ですね voxy v 都市部特別に不安
何します
先ほどと同じ作業したものがここにいろきっそうだしたものが
はいまさにあれを例えば3日ぐらい置いておくと大分ものがまあこれだと大
全く一緒ですね中にガラス管が入っていて
先に行ける10部が刺さっていて消化促進剤が入っていると
全く一緒の方がいい
じゃあ実際にやってみましょう
こういうふうに1本のガラスの中に
by あるのわかりますか
こちらのが細かいその際じまかにいっぱい出てますよね
もしはわりと大きめのものがポツポツと出ていますよね
地上で精一杯いい継承が出る上こちらルート下のほうがいいですけれどもを探して
このものを家よりもそのための下準備を
この部屋で行っている
これがあげるチューブですねそうですねアイター
転生作りますよ法案ですいや本当にその通りで
じゃあはしてですねそれタンパク質の結晶が
うわあああああ
乳房 a はい
一つの乱発2をの日の質を上げるためにも無数の条件で試してそれで初めて行く中
やっぱり宇宙実験粒期待が貴重なので切り
きり丸条件検討して
pk 症が出るように地上でくるいっぱい人権をしている
氷月を始めた
いやー
すごい
いろんなことがある
ブーブー1世妃アンナ
しかーし
masa ぜひなさいはい本当にありがとうございましたっ
がとうございましたはいということでですねなんとずう月の26日に
ザキさんのチャンネルで御爺さんと僕ですね
宇宙実験に関する講師イベントを行うことになりました
こちらですねなんと生配信ですのでぜひ皆さんたくさんの3年の方でご覧ください
でですね王子さんに質問したいこととか皆さん
宇宙に感謝したいことたくさんあると思うんですけどもぜひこの動画のコメント欄で
こういうことを聞いてみたいとか
こういうことを知りたいとかあったらぜひコメントで書いてみてください
ひょっとしたらライブイベント中に質問するかを知れません
今回ですね宇宙センター普段行けないようなところまで
千里させていただきます本当に今日はありがとうございました
群馬泉ましたとっても貴重な経験でいろんなことが勉強になりました
ザク砂チャンネルさんライブ配信楽しみにしててくださいばいばーい
me
うううう
いっ